bien vu vous les français veulent rester
libre à m'écouter et à suivre l'appel du
18 juin 1940 de l'autre côté de la
manche le général de gaulle appels à la
révolte contre vichy
c'était il ya 80 ans c'était les débuts
de radio londres radio londres ou
comment la résistance s'est lancé dans
la guerre des ondes depuis les locaux de
la bbc au deuxième sous-sol
les compagnons du général font passer
des messages sur le territoire français
[Musique]
personnel des bulletins d'information
pour contrer les récits de vichy et
d'autres messages plus énigmatique codé
afin d'organiser le soulèvement des
résistants
le chien de jardiniers place la
bibliothèque est en feu reçu en france
par la radio ce message est transmis à
des résistants il décrypte aussitôt la
manoeuvre un avion approche un échange
de signaux lumineux et voici une
livraison d'armes discrète sécurisé à
londres derrière le micro
une poignée d'hommes et de femmes se
relaient des comédiens des journalistes
des écrivains anime les ondes de la
tranche quotidienne les français parlent
aux français
parmi eux jean oberlé journalistes déjà
présent à londres avant le début de la
radio j'ai décidé de rester mais je ne
sais pas très bien ce que nous allions
faire on savait qu'on allait faire
quelque chose d'utile mais quoi et puis
tout à coup cette radio a pris forme
avec quelques-uns d'entre nous un jour
de 1944 un message personnel va changer
le cours de la guerre
une strophe de verlaine exactement de
passage l'un prononcé le 1er juin et
répété les trois jours suivants et la
fin de la strophe le 5 juin
noyé dans un flot de centaines de
messages sévère annonce le débarquement
nous qui étions deux micros nous
ignorions totalement le sens exact de
ces messages nous en connaissions
l'importance et nous savions qu'il
fallait évidemment les énoncés avec la
plus grande clarté ne changer ait la
moindre virgule ni la moindre syllabe de
juin 1940 à octobre 1944 radio londres a
été une arme de guerre la voie de la
résistance dans la france occupée avant
chacun des bulletins quatre notes de la
cinquième symphonie de beethoven
équivalent en morse de la lettre v comme
victoire
[Musique]